nickolas paddler discusses the protest
movement the challenged federal racial
segregation and discrimination during
the first two years of Woodrow Wilson's
presidency in his new book Jim Crow and
the Wilson administration this talk from
the University of Virginia in
Charlottesville is one hour
good afternoon I would like to welcome
you all to this annual event sponsored
by the library's multicultural issues
committee we'll go right into our
program and the introduction of the
guests author Nikolas paddler is a
resident of Stanton Virginia he holds a
Bachelor of Science degree in government
from Liberty University and a master's
degree in liberal arts with a
concentration in government from Harvard
University Division of Continuing
Education
he has written a number of articles for
various publications including the
journal of southern history as well as
peace review a journal of southern
justice his most recent article offers a
unique perspective and non violent
option for the palestinian-israeli
conflict his first book Jim Crow and the
Wilson administration protesting federal
segregation in the early 20th century
was released in February of 2004 by the
University Press of Colorado
he is currently adapting a screenplay
taken from the book and collaboration
with director Charles Burnett and Peggy
Trotter Damon priestly black based on
the tragic life of early equal rights
proponent William Monroe Trotter a
dedicated student of Mahatma Gandhi
Martin Luther King jr. and Albert Lee to
Lee and others mr. peddler is committed
to seeking solutions to non to violent
conflict through peaceful means such as
nonviolent direct action his hope is to
be actively involved in teach
people and conflict situations how to
use non-violent direct action both
strategically and morally to overthrow
oppressive regimes and achieve group
status objectives and empowerment so
without further ado I present to you mr.
Nicholas paddler thank you thank you
very much and thank you Colette that was
wonderful it's just an honor to be here
privilege to be here and I'm so glad you
all made time to come out and hear my
presentation today I'm going to be
talking about my book Jim Crow and the
Wilson administration so I'll just get
right into it with the election of
Woodrow Wilson in 1912 the South was
essentially swept back into power for
the first time in 50 years not only did
we have a southern born president in the
White House who had spent his formative
years in the deep south but some of the
most vociferous members of his newly
formed cabinet would be from the deep
south including some of their assistants
and underlings as well
Wilson's own party now controlled
Congress with a majority of 167 in the
House of Representatives and a majority
of 7 in the Senate and almost half of
these members would be Southern
Democrats out of the total 27 House and
Senate committees I'm sorry 24 out of
total 27 House and Senate committees
would be chaired by southerners and
amazingly the total number of votes cast
for Wilson in every southern state
sebastien surpassed the combined totals
for the bull moose Teddy Roosevelt and
Republican William Howard Taft so there
was definitely a change in the makeup of
the federal government in 1912 a strong
tilt towards southern power with the
south and control of the government now
essentially in control of the government
swarm of people from the south looking
for jobs from a party out of power for
so long came to Washington and when they
came to Washington this new southern
mindset in the federal government what
they saw in the federal bureaucracy
shocked them
on the eve of Woodrow Wilson's election
in 1912 over 12,000 African Americans
were working in the federal departments
in the nation's capital in almost every
in almost every department in managerial
and supervisory positions they were
working in a relatively integrated
environment and they were able that they
were able to achieve this upward
economic mobility which they had no
opportunity for anywhere else in the
private sector they were able to achieve
this by taking the relatively colorblind
civil service exam on an even par with
White's
nowhere else was this the case in the
country and so it enabled them to really
achieve economic status within the
federal government on an even par with
whites they were and as I said they're
working in almost every type of position
supervisory managerial managerial
positions they're african-american women
as well as men working in some of these
positions so you can imagine once the
South was back into Washington back in
power in Washington you could imagine
that they did not like this and almost
immediately they launched the campaign
to segregate african-americans but it
went much further than segregation they
actually downgraded african-americans
from their positions which means
essentially means they reclassified them
into lower paying positions with very
limited opportunities for advancement
and in many cases they were harassed and
they were terminated from their
positions as well so you can see that
things just weren't very well for
working out very well for
african-americans now in a federal
government the one last place that they
had in this country does every aspect of
life throughout the country even in the
north but in the deep south especially
every aspect of life for
african-americans was severely curtailed
they really as you know Jim Crow
dominated southern life they had no room
for economic advancement they couldn't
compete with whites as a free labor
force in the south and in many places in
the north as well and the main people
that led these segregation efforts are
Jim Crow and federal government where
Albert Burleson a southerner in the post
office department William give Gibbs
McAdoo in the Treasury Department
Josephus Daniels in the Navy Department
and many of their underlings and many of
their assistants
and this policy was sanctioned and
defended by President Woodrow Wilson
himself going back to at least the Civil
War times never had a policy like this
been sanctioned by present President of
the United States even though you did
have presidents who catered to white
supremacy you never had them overtly
promote and sanction and defend a Jim
Crow policy in the federal bureaucracy
this federal Jim Crow manifested itself
in many ways african-americans were
segregated on jobs in rooms where blacks
and whites had previously worked
together as integrated teams in other
rooms african-americans were petitioned
off from whites behind makeshift
partitions like lockers and various
things like that they were assigned the
least desirable jobs and forced into
inferior workspaces african-americans
were forced to use separate restrooms
for the first time in the Treasury and
post office departments and other
departments around Washington
colored signs in white signs began
appearing above restrooms often the
colored restrooms were far from the
workstations where African Americans
worked so they had to walk far whereas
White's their restrooms were very close
to their workstations in some cases
these were unisex facilities which meant
African American males and females used
the same restroom which most southern
whites would have been a gas consider
for themselves during these during this
time period they were required to sit at
separate lunch tables in the cafeterias
that were now labeled colored in whites
in some cases they were forced out of
the dining rooms altogether and two
makeshift dining rooms which are usually
in their locker rooms and dressing rooms
so you can see things really got bad for
African Americans but as I said federal
Jim Crow went much further than just the
segregation of African Americans as they
were downgraded and terminated from
their positions as well it was a
campaign just to get rid of them
White's one of the positions southern
whites especially one of these positions
and they didn't like what they saw they
did not like the integrated environments
that were in the departments and one of
their main complaints was they were
shocked to see white white black male
supervisors giving directions
instructions to white female employees
in these federal departments and
interestingly they couldn't use the old
argument in the South that was really
famous that african-americans were
inferior and that they needed to be
separated from rights the presence of so
many African Americans in a federal
departments in Washington refuted that
notion because African Americans had
achieved status they had competed with
whites on an even par and in fact and a
lot of the week's some and some of the
recorded test scores that I found just
sporadically listed in various papers
throughout the country I found that
sometimes African Americans actually had
the high scores on civil service exams
in the country so it was really a
refutation to the entire notion of a
black inferiority it really refuted all
the popular scientific studies of the
day that claimed over and over African
Americans had low IQs so now the
southerners that were in power in
Washington had to find a more defensible
argument and that argument was we don't
want white women working so close to
black men and of course that was just an
excuse to get rid of him but what my
book is really about and I talk about
this but what I really was amazed when
this book was in its earliest stages as
a graduate school thesis what really
amazed me is and this is 40 years before
the modern civil rights movement but
really what really amazed me is the fact
that tens of thousands of African
Americans and white sympathizers rose up
in protest against the Jim Crow policy
being expanded and initiated in the
federal government men women Native
Americans professionals - laborers they
rose up in protest and launched a
collective protest not seen since the
abolitionist movement and used a lot of
methods that really anticipated the
modern civil rights movement and I want
to try to go over some of these methods
with you because I think that some of
them were sporadic and some of them were
launched individually but most of these
were very strategic and they were
launched on a collective level and that
was pretty amazing for the times now
realize that this is the Progressive Era
this is you're talking about the second
decade of 20th century this is a time
and most people don't realize that such
a huge mass collective protest
movement against federal against
discrimination of racism of any kind
occurred so this was this was very
unusual most people most historians have
castigated african-americans during this
time period for being too divided over
apathy or to divide do divided over
various of a racial bitter opposition
over racial philosophies or personal
jealousies they just thought they were
just too divided and and plus the racism
this was a period of time in racism in
this country was at its zenith and many
felt that that after whatever that
african-americans did during that time
period probably didn't matter and so
they've really historians haven't really
looked at protests activism during this
period but I challenge those notions and
say that African Americans and whites
sympathizers did rise up they did care
deeply about the injustice that was
going on in federal government even
Booker T Washington believe it or not
came out from behind the shadows and
overtly protested against the spread of
federal segregation and discrimination
in the federal in the end of bureaucracy
in Washington but just to give you some
ideas of some of the methods they used
that I thought were very interesting
African Americans white sympathizers use
petitions mass meetings were held all
over the country in 1913 and 1914 they
signed petitions at these mass meetings
hundreds thousands of people signed
these petitions they either had them
hand-delivered to President Wilson
himself there were caught through a
sympathetic congressman or they either
sent mailed them to the President or in
some cases the petitions were actually
printed in newspapers all over the
country and African Americans and white
sympathizers signed the protest and
pasted all names and sent them to the
president one of the most amazing
petitions was one that was circulated by
early equal rights leader William Monroe
Trotter
William Road Trotter circulated a
petition in the first during the fall of
1913 the first to about in for about a
month and a half
circulated petition in 34 states and
managed to get 20,000 signatures and
realize this is a time of massive
technical technological communication it
was still in its infancy so that's
pretty amazing that he was able to do
that in about a month and a half
thirty-four states and get 20,000
signatures
and the interesting thing is that many
newspaper accounts that were talking
that really discuss this petition
claimed that over half of the signatures
on this petition were from the deep
south so utterly disempowered
southerners who are being crushed by
racism during this time period rose up
and were active participants in this
protest and I'll talk a little more
about southerners being in this protest
as well in a few minutes
African Americans and whites
sympathizers use the peels in the press
that was another method n-double-a-cp
sent protests and details of federal Jim
Crow to newspapers across the country
and interestingly again black newspapers
in the South usually to-to-to-to
cheaters or for shooters just small
newspapers with very limited space often
printed the details printed the protests
printed printed petitions and some even
commented editorially the protest the
protesters use publicity campaigns which
really overlaps with appeals in the
press but it was a little different
the n-double-a-cp and William Road
Trotter his organization which was
couldn't call the National independent
political league they would send the
latest protest Jim Crow details of what
was going on in Washington DC protests
details they were sending these this
information to large white newspapers
liberal white newspapers in white news
services across the country to try to
get publicity for their cause and these
were like the New York Times Associated
Press and other newspapers the
protesters used letter-writing campaigns
people from all over the nation wrote
letters to Woodrow Wilson to his cabinet
members to some of their assistants
protesting against federal Jim Crow this
was from east west north and south and
one interesting letter-writing campaign
I don't know if any of you are familiar
with Kari Allen McCray who wrote the
life of a Confederate generals black
daughter she's from Harrisonburg
Virginia in her book she describes her
grandmother's letter-writing campaign
incessantly to writing campaign to
Woodrow Wilson and her grandmother got
everybody in a neighborhood to write
letters to Woodrow Wilson protests neo2
policy
and they just sent these letters daily
to him asking him to reverse this policy
to do something to stop it I said just
take a moment to explain why this is so
important you know you know in a world
at a time when racism in this country
was at its zenith a recognition for
black achievement was something that was
very rare African Americans all over the
country realized that that that blacks
and the federal government had achieved
some status and they'd achievement that
status competing with whites and they
were proud of what they achieved they
had achieved some upward economic
mobility and they were very dismayed
when the federal government turned and
crushed their aspirations so this is the
reason that you had federal employees
also protesting this policy but the
federal employees were usually
protesting policies secretly a lot of
times African American federal employees
were actually supplying details and
information to protest organizations
like n-double-a-cp and the national
independent politically keeping them
informed another thing that the
protesters used was lobbying again they
lobbied women wrote rother
Oswald Garrison Villard who was the
chairman of the in double-a-c-p Mae
child's Nerney
who was the secretary of the N double
ACP and protestors from all over the
country really protests leaders from all
over the country really Lobby public
officials at the local state and
national levels to enlist their support
and they did believe it or not even
during this time period they did find
public officials who were very
sympathetic to their cause of course not
in the deep south but really almost
everywhere else and interestingly the
Massachusetts legislature sent an entire
collective protest to Wilson signed by
all the members protesting federal Jim
Crow and one person who they listed to
support their cause was honey Fitz or
John Fitzgerald the Irish Catholic mayor
of Boston who was the grandfather a
future President John F Kennedy he
actually protested in petitions letters
and impersonal meetings with Wilson
several times so I thought that was
pretty interesting I thought that was
pretty neat and one that I really
a method that these early protesters
used that I really think anticipates the
modern civil rights movement was direct
confrontation Trotter
wait a minute Trotter had William a
Trotter international independent
politically his delegation of protesters
had met with Wilson two times over the
racist policy in federal government once
in November of 1913 another time in
November of 1914 and let me just back up
a little minute a minute and explain a
little bit about William Errol Trotter
the wrong Bennett jr. says he's the
singularly most neglected figure in
african-american history the best way to
try to explain to you some of you may be
familiar with him but there hasn't been
a lot written about him only a few
things here and there there's been one
biography that's been written about him
in nineteen sixties and I'm afraid that
the biography doesn't end very well I
think it's kind of inaccurate but the
best way to try to help you understand
who a Trotter is if you take the passion
of Martin Luther King jr. and the
intensity of Malcolm X and you combine
them into one person and throw them
about 50 years ahead of their time
that's what this guy was like you had
one frustrated black man he was a
visionary he was way ahead of his time
he was trying to do what Martin Luther
King jr. and Malcolm X and Ralph
Abernathy and Jesse Jackson he was
trying to do what they were trying to do
but he was trying to do it 50 years
ahead of their time
so that's what this guy was like he was
born as a lot of people call him a
Boston black elite in 1872
he went to an all-white High School
where he graduated as valedictorian and
student body president he went to
Harvard College where in his freshman
year he earned the Distinguished
deuter's award for academic achievement
and in his junior year he was inducted
in the Phi Beta Kappa and he graduated
from Harvard as magnet as a magna [ __ ]
laude which was pretty impressive and
his father had a pretty lucrative real
estate business in Boston so people kind
of expected him to fall back into that
not that elite lifestyle enjoy the
luxury and just enjoy a comfortable life
but amazingly around the turn of the
century amazingly and I emphasize that
he turned his back on the elite life
that beckons him and he went into the
most dangerous business an
african-american man could go into at
that time and that was fighting for
black across struggling for black
equality and fighting
against racial injustice so he's an
amazing character and his whole life is
just a roller coaster ride it's just an
utter roller coaster ride of fighting
confronting people have a racial
injustice getting beaten getting thrown
in jail he ended up losing his wife who
was also in the struggle with him
prematurely - an influenza epidemic he
essentially was ostracized by many of
the other elite african-american elite
in Boston and don't get me wrong the
elite african-american elite in Boston
cared a lot about black political civil
rights they just couldn't understand
Trotters obsession with a cause with
this cause at the expense of everything
even family Trotter essentially went
broke he lost all his money but he kept
going he kept fighting he kept he kept
struggling and he died he died
prematurely at age 62 in 1934 but just
kind of wanted to give try to put him in
spective and give you a little bit about
his background
anyway he met with Wilson two times in
1913 once in 1913 once in 1914 the ones
that time in 1913 Ida Wells Barnet who
many of you are probably familiar with
she met she was with him and they both
spoke to Wilson and protested against a
policy Wilson at this point this is this
is pretty this is you know right federal
discrimination had only been really
getting bad for about three or four
months Wilson kind of played dumb and
said oh I didn't know that things were
so bad I'll look into it
and so he essentially promised the
protesters and he would look into it
they knew he was bluffing but they
figured at least they can put him on
record is promising to look into it so
they left but things got much worse over
the next year and they went back they
managed amazingly they managed to set up
a second meeting with President Wilson
and this time the meeting got very
heated and Wilson and Trotter got into a
major argument and over federal Jim Crow
Wilson said he agreed with the policy he
had sanctioned a policy and he admitted
that he was defending the policy and
this really made Trotter may I try -
went off on Wilson Wilson went off on
Trotter they went back and forth and
essentially made national and
national news newspapers from all over
picked up the meeting they just couldn't
believe that a black man would stand in
the White House and speak to the
president like this but believe it or
not a lot of newspapers were sympathetic
to Trotter they agreed with what he's
doing they thought he had a right to do
to speak to the president that way and
of course the European newspapers really
thought he had a right to speak to the
president that way they were really on
his side but what I want to do real
quick I just want to stop my talk here
and I have actually written a screenplay
on trotters life which has recently been
accepted by a director named Charles
Burnett in Los Angeles and professor
Jordan is kind enough has been kind
enough to offer services to read some of
the lines with me and the lines that
we're going to read from this from this
particular scene are are from the second
meeting that Trotter had with Wilson
so mr. Jordan would come up please and
again this is in the white house this is
at the White House it's November 12th
1914 Trotter is standing there with what
with four or five members of his
delegation Woodrow Wilson is seated at
his desk his Irish Catholic secretary is
sitting there his transcriber Charles
Swim is taking notes and this is what
happens and I'll begin mr. president we
are here to renew our protests against
the segregation of African Americans in
the departments of our national
government Jim Crow not only can be
found in these departments but it has
spread since our meeting a year ago the
meeting incidentally in which you
promised that you would look into our
complaints we now ask that you once and
for all abolish the mistreatment of
African Americans an executive branch of
the United States government
segregations sir is an absurd
arrangement and a humiliation for
African Americans people on the streets
of the national capital are free to use
the restrooms in government buildings
while blacks employed in these buildings
buildings are forbidden to use them we
are entitled at your hands to freedom
from discrimination restriction and
insult and government employment have
you a new freedom for white Americans
and a new slavery for your afro-american
fellow citizens
god forbid segregation mr. Trotta in my
opinion as well as my colleagues in the
department is a practical solution to
the inevitable friction that arises when
the two races are mixed
it seems the best way to help the [ __ ]
out this time
we are giving him an opportunity to
advance along separate lines without
interference my cabinet moreover has
assured me that Negro employees are not
at a disadvantage and that each race
receives equal treatment if all is equal
then answer this how do you explain the
present condition in the departments
where it has already operated the
detriment of so many colored employees
where some have been placed in a
position where they're now humiliated
and indisposed having to go far from
their work just to use the toilet rooms
where they're being reduced from
clerkships to laborers and forced right
out of departments entirely I haven't
known of such incidents I think this
whole thing has been exaggerated your
attitude were only stirred up resentment
among the Negro masses and make things
worse mr. president we did not come to
the White House as delegates of this
league protesting Jim Crow in the
attitude of dependent Ward's of the
nation but it's full-fledged American
citizens absolutely equal with all
others to demand our equal rights under
the Constitution is untenable in view of
the established facts to maintain that
segregation is simply to avoid race
friction for the simple reason that for
50 years white and colored clerks have
been working together in peace and
harmony and frenum friendliness
segregation was drastically introduced
after inauguration by your own employee
appointees this policy is far from being
in the best interest of African
Americans it's a sham to suggest such
the truth of the matter is that Jim Crow
is due to nothing other than the race
prejudice on the part of the official
who puts it into operation we are
greatly disappointed in you mr.
president for your lack of moral
aptitude in regard to Jim Crow if this
organization is to have another hearing
before me it must have another spokesman
your tone sir offends me please tell me
and what way am i offensive you are the
only American citizen that has ever come
into this office who has talked to me
with passion that was evident but I have
no passion in me mr. president
you're entirely mistaken you
misinterpret my earnestness for passion
two years ago you were regarded as a
second Abraham Lincoln I would
appreciate no personal references my
intent will become clear if you allow me
to continue I am the one to do the
interrupting here mr. Trotter we color
leaders are now being denounced as
traitors to our race what do you mean by
traitors because we advise the colored
peep
to support your ticket I resent that mr.
Trotter bringing in the political issue
is blackmail it's evident that you don't
understand what this is like for colored
federal employees I wish to earnestly
plead with you to put an end to Jim Crow
in two federal departments I think this
meeting should come to an end my burdens
as president are more than the human
spirit can carry mr. president I take
responsibility if my tone seemed
offensive but I think your quick
judgment regard to my passion was a
mistake Oh we'll call it all right just
one more word mr. president we were only
trying to bring about racial harmony
throughout the country segregation only
intensifies the misunderstanding and
mistrust between the races so that just
kind of sets things I think kind of
gives you a good perspective what things
were like then the issues of the day and
of course this contentious meeting
between Weimar Oh Trotter and President
Wilson
needless to say Wilson never would give
Trotter an audience again he would never
meet with the Trotter he even became
upset with Trotter and had referred to
him
ironically enough as that despicable fit
person Tucker Tucker a lot of you may
not realize was a way to mask the more
traditional racial slur of the time
which was the n-word
Tucker Joseph Lewis Tucker was an
Episcopal clergyman in the late 1800s
who synthesized the theme of black
retrogression which essentially made
which essentially maintained that blacks
in the absence of the bonds of slavery
were regressing instinctively
to sexual predation and were declining
morally and at cyclopædia Britannica
actually in 1884 called Tucker an expert
on the fact that Negroes are non moral
so if you ever come across the term
Tucker generally it's a negative term
especially when you hear southerners or
anybody during the Progressive Era and
before
that time referring to african-american
success Tucker's so the protests
continued and with all the methods that
I've described there's a few more
besides a direct confrontation it was
also a march in Boston the protest Jim
Crow the most people don't realize that
a march occurred this early on
that was that was a protesting racial
discrimination and trying to obtain
black equality but it did it occurred in
Boston on December 1st 1913 two
different protesters started from two
different sections of Boston merged half
way sung spirituals and ended up at
Faneuil Hall where they held a huge
protest meeting where petitions were
signed and sent to President Wilson
again this is 40 years before the modern
civil rights movement I hope this
occurred African Americans and whites
sympathizers galvanized black
communities to get them involved in the
protest the n-double-a-cp worked hard to
get field workers out all over the
country to try to get communities people
involved organizations churches people
from all over and then in double-a-c-p
during this time it's interesting Lee
it's interestingly it was driven by
largely by women there were men on in
the leadership roles but women on then
at the national level over 29 women
served in positions on the national
level
82 women served as positions
high-profile positions in branches all
around the country one woman was
actually president of the Seattle branch
miss Leticia graves so women were active
participants
they were the engines and then double
acp and they were really out there
protesting and trying to get support and
other people enlisted to confront the
federal government over Jim Crow then
double AC P and Trotter and other
protesters used networking again this is
a time when massive technological
communication is in its infancy but they
managed to Usenet they manage the
network with branches and other states
and other cities to help them set up
meetings all over and again you know
the telephone is fairly new on the scene
1913 1914 maybe 1/4 the third of
households had them certainly lower
income households didn't have them the
radio wouldn't become a common household
item for conveying information until the
1920s with improved technology so this
is pretty amazing stuff that's going on
and the final method that they used
which I really believe also anticipates
the modern civil rights movement are the
mass meetings that were held all over
the country everywhere except the deep
south
these massive meetings again were huge
hundreds the thousands of people they
were held from new york Topeka Kansas to
Seattle Washington to Northern
California
again this is 1913 1914 not 1950 or 1960
one meeting that really I thought was
amazing was held at the Metropolitan AME
Church in Washington DC on the night of
October 27th 1913 this meeting had four
to five thousand people packed in the
church to hear the latest about Jim Crow
and the protest by petition and had an
overflow of about three to four thousand
people outside of the church now this
and several other meetings were as big
some one were even bigger than the ones
held in the modern civil rights era they
were electrifying they were dynamic they
were usually heard they were usually
held in churches and sanctuaries all
over the country they sang hymns
speakers would get up and speak
passionately about Jim Crow the remarks
were punctuated by tell the truth
brother and aim in the same things that
we would see in the modern civil rights
movement for this early period Trotter
after a second meeting with Woodrow
Wilson William Errol Trotter was the
held mass meetings in a few cities
around the country these mass meetings
were utterly different from anything
that had been held before because they
were utterly utterly african-americans
felt a burst of optimism Trotter had
stood up to a white leader who is
supporting Jim Crow and in their eyes
has scored at least the symbolic victory
so they many people felt like an Arab
air revocable step towards black
equality had been taken they would
shortly thereafter be very very
disappointed but for at least a month or
two after
and Wilson's after Trotter Wilson's
meeting the second time they felt
optimistic and the mass meetings that
Trotter was a part of he would stand up
on the stage and when he would stand up
on the stage people would go crazy they
would just clap for a minute five
minutes ten minutes at a time and when
try to try to speak they would just keep
clapping for him and he would have to
wait for him to calm down they would
pound their fists they would pound there
they would stomp their feet and whenever
Trotter would describe his meeting with
Wilson they would just they were just
overjoyed they were just on fire they
were just possessed and they were just
just yelling and saying Amen and yes and
tell the truth and clapping and the roof
sound like the roof was gonna you know
just explode off the church and whenever
Trotter would mention Wilson's name they
would hiss and boo and talk about
throwing him out of the White House and
things like that so these meetings were
a little more I'm not sure if aggressive
is the right word but there is a little
more energetic than some of them other
meetings that have been held even a lot
of meetings are pretty interject these
meetings were just it was just just an
energetic atmosphere very dynamic now
was the protest a success this amazing
early protest
unfortunately no it was not exercised if
things got much worse on the protest was
drowned out by the advent of World War 2
World War one in Europe newspapers
around the country quick-quick printing
on protest details or at least prayer to
put them on the very back pages and a
little tiny little miniature articles
that nobody read because they couldn't
talk about anything else than World War
one they were debating whether neutral
neutrality was possible and if
neutrality wasn't they were wondering
when the United States would enter World
War one so it was drowned out the
protest and his federal Jim Crow which
drowned out prematurely
and things got worse in the federal
government african-american status
declined until 10-15 years later the
only positions you could really find the
men were in custodial positions and
things stayed that way until Franklin
Delano Roosevelt issued executive order
8802 in 1941 which essentially banned
racial discrimination in the booming
defense industry
the federal government but with that
said the protest was a success in
another way it brought together
african-americans and whites sympathizer
sympathizers collectively for the first
time on such a huge level and it
challenged the Booker T Washington
argument that that african-americans if
they build themselves up economically
White's they will they will soon they
will sooner or later get the
respectability of whites well in the
federal government african-americans did
build themselves up economically they
did integrate the federal government
they did have status and the federal
government turned and utterly crushed
them so now the Booker T Washington it
was really a watershed event which which
which challenged the Booker T Washington
argument and it no longer seemed too
many to be a viable alternative
so now after Wilson protests you see
black nationalism rising to a large
degree Marcus Garvey me not a Negro
Improvement Association you see the
radical left coming to the fore to a
lesser extent never became very popular
in this country but they were there and
you see African Americans considering
the potential of collective black power
as a force for racial advancement and
you see African Americans flowing into
organizations of augmenting the
membership roles of organizations such
as the National Association of colored
women such as a National Urban League
the Marcus Garvey's United Negro
Improvement Association
the n-double-a-cp interestingly on the
eve of Woodrow Wilson's election in
double-a-c-p
I believe had somewhere around a
thousand members by the end of Wilson's
second term that number had grown to
over a hundred thousand nationwide and
that doesn't include the number of
African Americans in the deep south who
couldn't really join for fear of violent
reprisal who really sympathize with so
you're probably talking about probably
twice three or four times that many who
sympathize with in double-a-c-p
so there was a change robert Bagnall who
was n-double-a-cp officer in the 1920s
notice this change
and african-americans in their mindset
in how they're approaching the racial
problems of their day after the Wilson
years and he said the old Negro has
passed away a new Negro is here he is
restless discontented ambitious and
eager so there was a change and
african-americans did start protesting
n-double-a-cp
has been criticized for not being more
and not being a more aggressive protest
organization they've been criticized
sometimes in those early days for moving
towards legal action but realize that
their approach was radical in the sense
that they took the white man's own legal
apparatus and turned the juror or legal
racism on its head by challenging
incessantly Jim Crow and racism in this
country statute by statute case by case
law by law until the edifice of Jim Crow
began to crumble so you see they weren't
successful in stopping Jim Crow in
federal government but they were
successful and forming a new I think
collective consciousness that we would
see really come to the fore in the
modern civil rights movement I think
they help set the tone and groundwork
for the modern civil rights movement I
certainly think William Monroe Trotter
who's been neglected and I hope he'll
get his due now because unfortunately a
lot of african-americans sites even
during Black History Month rarely
mentioned William Monroe Trotter and I
think he's extremely important for
setting the tone to the modern civil
rights movement it was emphasis on on
direct confrontation which was used in
the modern civil rights movement and his
emphasis on integration and trying to
gain trying to achieve black equality so
Trotter is is very important and I think
I'm sad sometimes because I don't think
people in the modern civil rights
movement the leaders or the participants
remember Trotter they remembered you
know other leaders even w/e be the voice
by the way he was a friend of trotters
who believe it or not in the early days
in 1900 1901 1902 Trotter actually
criticized for not being radical enough
because we kind of associate that we
need the voice as being very radical but
Trotter felt like
a lot of people realize w-2 voice was
aligned with Booker T Washington in his
early days and that upset Trotter
Trotter eventually left the side of
Booker T Washington if you ever say
who's really at the side of Booker T
Washington but he because I don't think
he wholeheartedly embraced Washington's
policy of building ourselves up
economically and forgetting about
fighting for our rights and struggling
against racial justice but he did become
more radical and aligned himself more
with Trotter and but his protest was
very different from trotters Trotter was
active protest Trotter is what we would
see with King and Malcolm X actively
confronting those responsible for racial
injustice whereas the boys mostly
protested through scholarship articles
and many of you are familiar with the
souls of black folk and that was
trotters method but now I thought I
would just open it up to any questions
that you all may have feel free yes
I'm curious if Trotter tried to combine
his protest efforts with any of the
other protest efforts at the time which
I would think would include women not
friends others absolutely
Trotter's Trotter had an organization
called the National independent
political League it went through several
incarnations changed names several times
I don't know why I never could find out
but no Trotter actually worked within
double ACP his organization in the
n-double a-c-p served as the umbrella
organizations as well as the engines in
this protest movement and a lot of them
shared membership as well Trotter didn't
wholeheartedly align himself within
double ACP because he felt that there
are too many white members and then
double ACP and they were watered down
it's militancy Trotter wasn't prejudiced
at all he just felt like that white
people just couldn't understand their
urgency the sense of urgency that was
needed an intensity that was needed in
their struggle but yes it did they did
work together in this movement they did
share a membership there were a lot of
women I'm working in this movement in
both organizations so yes yes you spoke
a little bit about the correlation
between what the modern civil rights
movement came to our generations to be
known as how do you think they were
inspired by what Trotter in in the early
years of Booker T what they were doing
during that time period in the modern
yeah how were they were how were they
did they take inspiration from what
Trotter did and the methods that he
employed well I think Trotter did set
the tone in groundwork for the modern
civil rights movement again his emphasis
on his use of direct confrontation which
is which was kind of ahead of its time
his emphasis on integration his emphasis
on struggling against racial injustice
and fighting for black equality I think
did set the tone definitely for the
modern civil rights woman but again I
just don't think I found no evidence in
the modern civil rights movement that
they were aware of Trotter he set the
tone but I don't think they were aware
of the person of Trotter they were aware
I think of what he did I think they
benefited from what he did but they just
weren't aware as far as Booker T
Washington I'm not so sure how Booker T
watching may have inspired modern civil
rights movement I think people were
beginning to move
his philosophy had already you know kind
of was was challenged and it was it was
demonstrated that it wouldn't work that
african-americans couldn't build
themselves up economically and hope that
just somehow whites were going to accept
them without their political and civil
rights I think most people after the
Wilson years realized that
african-americans yes build yourselves
up economically but we also need the
fight for our political and civil rights
to in some form or another yes
in our times today Woodrow Wilson is
considered a revered figure by many
there's a bridge named after him in DC
he was a war president and a successful
war president their efforts in this
state to commemorate him to build a new
library to commemorate him how do we
today reconcile Woodrow Wilson with the
aspiration that African American is
doing his time and today it's a very
good question which were Wilson did make
things much worse for african-americans
Woodrow Wilson did have a strong
segregationist mindset he was given
impetus I think from his strongly
southern cabinet and the people that
were around him and from his wife Ellen
axon Wilson he was had the strong
segregationist mindset which were
Wilson's ideal Woodrow Wilson at best
can be described his attitude to be
strived at best as overwhelmingly
paternalistic towards african-americans
his idea of better race relations was
the most limited contact and interaction
between blacks and whites possible so he
did make things much worse for
african-americans so I understand why
people get upset about the bridge
proposed bridge in Maryland well it's
already named after Woodrow Wilson but I
think they didn't want the medallion of
Woodrow Wilson on the side and the on
the Maryland side I can understand that
listen did make things much harder
Wilson and people ask me I'm a friend
came up to me and he said well which a
Wilson grew up in the south you just
have to understand you know that's just
the way he couldn't beat south he had
that mindset he that was his environment
that's what he was taught that's what he
experienced on daily basis and I said
that's very true that's very true and we
have to take that in consideration when
we consider Wilson's racial views but
you have to understand that wasn't
didn't stay in Deep South Wilson went
north he was the President of Princeton
University he was the governor of New
Jersey he had a lot of his academic
colleagues people that he interacted
with our daily basis we're from schools
like Harvard and Dartmouth and Yale who
didn't agree with what he was doing in
the federal government by segregating
african-americans Wilson had friends on
his club one of his good friends was
Oswald Garrison Villard chairman of the
n-double a-c-p grandson of the fiery
abolitionist William Lloyd Garrison who
kept Wilson informed of what was going
on and actually protested against his
friend and actually turned against his
friend
you had great standard Baker which will
Wilson's first Commission bought of her
who was a good friend of Woodrow
Wilson's who went salad he did a tour of
the South in 1908 in 1907 1908 and wrote
a book talking about how sudden there's
really want to keep African Americans
down they really want African Americans
is a cheap labor force they don't want
them to get education they don't want
them to have any chance for upward
economic mobility they really want to
keep them down and raise standard
Baker's shared this with Wilson he was a
close friend of Wilson and Wilson had
other friends so you got to balance that
out yes his environment did play a large
part in who he was and his racial views
but at the same time he didn't stay in
that environment he's surrounded himself
with with the world that was really
different from from the world that he
grew up in in the war-torn South and
during the Reconstruction era so as far
as people studying Wilson today I guess
you just have to look at it you just
have to take take a balance of you I
tell people you know as much as I'm
disappointed in Wilson because I grew up
living across the street from his
birthplace and and and I really want to
like Wilson because there's some things
about Wilson I do like but he miserably
despite his lofty rhetoric for justice
liberty and equality that a ought that
often just was replete in all of his
speeches many of his speeches and Spike
his Christian rhetoric that attracted
many african-americans to him in the
campaign of 1912 Wilson miserably
miserably failed african-americans but
there are certain aspects of Wilson I
really admire I really admired of
Woodrow Wilson who fought better League
of Nations who came back who once he
realized he wasn't gonna get the support
in the Senate for his League of Nations
after he left Versailles he came back
here into the whirlwind tour around the
United States trying to get grassroots
support for the League of Nations most
scholars criticize him for this but I
admire him for that I admire his fire
and passion they try to get his League
of Nations past and if the Senate wasn't
gonna do it if he wasn't gonna get the
political support from the elites in
Washington and he was gonna go to the
people and I admire him for that so I
think he needs to be looked at in a
balanced perspective but he did utterly
utterly miserably fail african-americans
I would be interested in here you
hearing you elaborate more on I to be
Wells Barnett and and trotters efforts
and organizations that they might have
individually been involved in yeah thank
you
well let me just say I love auto wills
Barnet is she's seventy years before
Rosa Parks Ida Wells Barnett refused me
you know the story she refused to go to
the back of a train or refused to leave
the white section of a train and give up
her seat to a white man and was forcibly
thrown off of that train this was in
1884 she sued in the lower courts in one
it went at a Tennessee Supreme Court
which was dominated at that by this time
by former Confederates and she lost she
was she was Trotters she was he was a
female version of William Monroe Trotter
they were good friends they liked each
other they enjoyed each other's company
she formed a branch of trotters national
independent political league with her
Negro fellowship League in Chicago and
kind of merged into organizations she
protes when the first meeting with
Wilson in 1913 Ida Wells Barnett went
with him went with Trotter and she was
only it was a Trotter addressed Wilson
and the only other delicate to address
Wilson that this first meeting was Ida
wells Barnett and I thought how amazing
here you have a black woman who's doubly
disempowered she's black and she's a
woman she can't sit in the second
section of the Train she wants to sit
him about without being forcibly removed
she can't vote she can't go anywhere
here she is standing up in protest in
front of a white Southern born president
and what she told him was pretty amazing
she told him that the only way President
Wilson you can understand what this
thing is like for my people is for you
to wear a face that is black or brown so
I thought wow wow and I thought what was
going through Wilson's mine because he
idolized the southern Victorian white
woman he scorned suffrage fighters like
Ida Wells Burnett who during Wilson's
inauguration had marched in the suffrage
played a suffrage a female suffrage pray
I'm so I thought what was going on ER
Wilson's mind when she was speaking I'd
love to see his face when I was born I'd
like to see his face when tried I was
speaking to him but I really like to see
his face when Ida Wells Barnett stood up
to speak to him interestingly Wilson's
own transcriber Charles swim
attributed those remarks the William
Monroe Trotter but I went back and found
trotters newspaper and a lot of other
people and speeches and everything and
out of wills Barnett had said those
remarks so wonder if Charles Swim did
that on purpose I'm wondering how
Trotter and other leaders in this
protest against reintroduction of Jim
Crow and the federal government felt
about the war both when we were in a
neutral you know both when we were sort
of sitting on the fence and then later
when we entered the war was the war
something was considered irrelevant or
or not I have to think of Martin Luther
King coming to the conclusion that the
Vietnam War was very relevant to the
struggle for civil rights but in this
case was it different that's a really
good question
and I really haven't looked into that in
in-depth but what I have found is that
they differed some people some of the
protesters eventually believe that we
should be in the war other protesters
adamantly believed that we shouldn't be
involved in the war and they were
pacifists like Oswald garrison Billard
who was the chairman of the white
chairman of the n-double a-c-p
the National Association of colored
women protested vigorously about
entering into the war we were a Trotter
no I'm really not sure where he stood i
Kevin found much about what he's what
his opinions of the war but there were
other people and african-americans who
did not think we belonged in this war
they figured we had enough to do here at
home WB Dubois I think was initially
against going into war but I think he
eventually agreed with it because I
think he was involved wasn't he involved
with trying to promote a black unit and
black officers commissioned officers in
World War one so I think they differ
just like everybody else but one person
who really stood up and said thought
that the worst possible thing we could
do the most evil thing we could do
morally
his entering by entering and entering
this war one of the people that really
promoted that viewpoint was Oswald
garrison Villard the grandson of William
Lloyd Garrison who utterly with Woodrow
Wilson's stance on federal Jim Crow and
then finally with Woodrow Wilson
dragging America into what he thought
was a dangerous and immoral war
Oswald Garrison billard ugly turned
against his friend and never wanted to
have anything to do it with Jill Wilson
he thought Woodrow Wilson at that point
was the worst president we've ever had
and so I wish I could give you a better
answer any other questions I was
wondering if you know if the crisis
magazine which was the publication of
the n-double a-c-p if there was much
coverage in that magazine especially
editorial coverage criticizing Wilson's
position about the federal workers and
supporting Trotters actions in regard to
that absolutely the crisis was right on
it the crisis was putting at crisis was
not only printing protest in printing
letters and different things like that
they were printing newspapers from all
over the nation even specially southern
newspapers that were printing things
about the protest this isn't that that's
pretty amazing that southern newspapers
would be involved during this period of
time but the good thing is they're their
newspapers are usually ignored by the
whites in those areas so it was kind of
a safe thing to do but the fact that
they did care deeply about the Justice
that was going on and trotter printed
these in the crisis truck I mean the
boys the boys who was who was in charge
of the crisis printed these in the
crisis he printed trotters protested in
the crisis he printed everything crises
are just full packed it's a great
resource for this movement a great
resource for this movement
I call Trotter Steinbeck II and
character he's his life is fascinating
and it's utterly tragic as I mentioned
earlier he lost everything he became
very I think he suffered from some form
of depression
he became very disoriented end of his
life he kept fighting he kept fighting
but he was disoriented he was feeling he
was he was he was ostracized he didn't
have a whole lot of friends people just
thought he was too dangerous too much of
a fireball his methods were just way
ahead of their times and his times just
had trouble accommodating him he was a
visionary and Trotter kept became more
and more disoriented as he got older and
at the end of his life he died he he was
he was living in an apartment that his
sister owned and it was a flat roof
apartment Boston and he had a habit of
going up to the flat roof and pacing
back and forth the thing and it got the
point where he's pacing back and forth
and he was mumbling to himself he was
talking to himself one night he went up
the pace back and forth back and forth
and he fell off the roof of the
apartment and he died I wish I'd have
brought some of the eulogies with me
because the eulogies are amazing that
the people wrote for the time just
writing about him being lunch Chicago
WIPP he's talking about how he was a
pathetic character who lost the support
of his people and lost his cause and
then in another tone it said but he
stands defiant you know still ready to
battle Jim Crow I wish I had it
memorized because I think you would
enjoy it I should have brought it thank
you very much
it was an honor thank you all so much
for coming out please feel free to help
yourself to refreshments and make some
mingle with the author thank you Jim
Crow and the Wilson administration is
Nicholas paddlers first book it's
published by University Press of
Colorado visit yupi Colorado com for
more information